-Guys, thank you for that.
-Congrats.
"Almost Famous" on Broadway.
-It's wild.
-Let's talk about this.
This is unbelievable.
I mean, you've directed some of
the most beloved movies
ever made --
"Almost Famous,"
"Jerry Maguire,"
"Fast Times at Ridgemont High."
You've written for
"Rolling Stone."
I mean, how does it go
from creating
books, articles, movies
to Broadway?
-And getting to direct you
along the way in the movie.
-No big deal. Yeah.
My first big movie role
ever was in "Almost Famous."
No big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-But is it tough?
Who did you meet with?
You must have studied.
I know you.
-Yeah.
-You must have jumped into this.
-I did.
My friend Lia Vollack
is a huge music fan,
and she kind of turned into
a Broadway producer of renown.
And she said to me, "You know,
I can make this fun for you."
And "Almost Famous"
is the one thing, I think,
I've been involved with that
had the most recurring fan talk,
and people would always
want to talk about
the feeling
that the movie gave them.
And I thought, "You know,
if we can get that feeling
on a live stage in a theater,
that's almost like
the 1973 world that
the movie is based on."
-Yeah.
-So just to kind of
get that kind of --
You're immersed in 1973,
and that music feeling
with this cast
has been totally exciting.
-Yeah. You get to -- Obviously,
some of the songs that we know
from the movie are in this.
But there's also some original
great songs in here, as well,
that you had
your hand in writing.
How is Cameron Crowe
writing a real song?
-Well, you know, I don't have
the body of work that
"Weird Al" Yankovic has
or you with "Almost Too Early
for Christmas" and stuff.
-We're currently in litigation.
We'll figure that out.
-I'm rooting for it.
-Thanks. Me too.
-Yeah. Tom Kitt,
the wonderful composer,
was involved in this
from the very beginning.
And we kind of
wrote songs together,
and he showed me how you can
actually jump over into
writing story songs
that the characters can sing.
And in musical theater,
that's the close-up you get.
Because they always say,
"Well, you don't get
a close-up in theater,"
but you get those songs,
which give you
the deep feelings of
the characters.
And Tom kind of, you know,
was involved in teaching me
how to do that,
and it's been a blast.
-When you went on tour,
no matter who it was,
you were a kid with
"Rolling Stone."
You were with Led Zeppelin.
You were with
The Allman Brothers.
-You never go like,
"Oh, maybe I'll be a rock star.
Maybe I'll start doing --
Maybe I'll start writing songs
or performing." No?
-I never could really play and I
never was in a band, really.
But there was one moment
about kind of --
I think it was 16 or 17,
and I was writing about
The Allman Brothers Band
and on tour with them,
which is a lot of what
the "Almost famous" story
is based on.
And we were in this hotel room
in the Continental Hyatt House.
And The Allman Brothers Band
is like a family,
and they've all got guitars and
they're playing this blues song.
And Gregg Allman
is right in front of me,
and he's playing this blues
song, "Come On in My Kitchen."
And I see this great guitar next
to me that nobody's playing.
-Yeah.
-So I thought, "You know,
this is how it works."
So, I pick up this guitar,
not knowing how to play at all,
and just start strumming.
-Yeah.
-And feelin' it.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
And Gregg Allman
looks over at me
and then he kind of looks
over -- just over my shoulder
and gives a nod,
and I'm thinking,
"He digs what I'm doing."
And then, a moment later,
these hands appear
and kind of lift the guitar
out of my hands.
And it was like,
"Your moment in heaven is over."
[ Sad tuba plays ]
You know.
Love the band, like the band,
interview the band.
-Yeah.
-Don't jam with the band.
-They don't want you
to jam with them.
-No.
-No. When we shot this,
it was the most fun
experience of my life.
I had so much fun,
and you loved everybody.
Everyone loved you.
It was just magic
when we were doing it.
And I remember, about halfway
through, maybe towards the end,
there was no real title
for the film.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember this?
-I do.
-Or you had an idea for it --
to call it "Untitled"? No.
-I thought we could
call it, like,
after a Led Zeppelin album,
you know?
Where it has no title,
it has symbols.
So, the idea was we'd have
this movie that was untitled,
but you could ask for it
by symbols.
And the DreamWorks
department marketing
really just did not groove
with me on that.
-So, yeah,
you have this great movie.
You have no title for it?
-Yeah, they would say like,
"You know, nobody's going to
come up to the box office
and say,
'I want two tickets for the
symbols movie.'"
Or the untitled movie.
-So, we -- As you remember,
we had such a good time
making the movie,
but we were so addicted to
the idea of no title
that one day,
we knew we had to
come up with something.
So, there was
a suggestion box on the set,
and people would stuff
all these names in there
for what the title could be.
And you, my friend, came up with
a very significant list,
which I kept.
-Are you serious?
-And I would like
to share this with you
20-some years later.
Here are your ideas
for the title
of what would become
"Almost Famous."
-This is actually --
This is really my --
This is how bad
my handwriting is.
You kept this?
-Yes.
-I'm freaking out. Cameron...
-No, it's good.
-But this is wild.
-Yeah.
-This is real.
That's legit.
-Yeah.
"Vinyl Days"
was my favorite, Jimmy.
I thought that was pretty great.
-"Vinyl Days." Not bad.
"I'm with the Band."
[ Light laugher ]
It's getting chuckles.
"Pages."
-"Pages." Interesting.
-It's deep.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I thought "pages,"
like you're writing pages for
a magazine, but, also,
it's pages of your life.
-Exactly. I like --
I'm with you.
I'm with you on this.
"I'm on the List"
is kind of interesting.
-"I'm on the List."
[ Laughs ]
"The 33 1/3 Incher"?
-Yeah.
-It's about a record.
-It's about up there
with the symbols.
-Yeah, yeah, symbols. Yep.
What -- Then I started
getting just silly.
-"Doin' It."
-Yeah, "Doin' It."
That was like 'cause,
"Hey, we're doin' it."
-Yeah.
Wow. Yeah.
Some of them
are real bad, too, yeah.
"Vinyl Reality."
-I like "Vinyl Reality."
-Yeah, that was before
"Virtual Reality," right?
-These are big swings
you're taking.
-I'm taking -- Yeah,
I'm taking big swings on this.
Oh, my gosh. "Gather No Moss"?
That's a little embarrassing.
But I thought "Rolling..."
Yeah, yeah.
-I like it.
-Yeah, nope.
I'm so happy you
went with "Almost Famous."
-It seems to fit.
-You know, the last time --
I'm not kidding.
The last time I grew a beard
in my entire life ever
was for you and for this movie.
This is me as my chara--
your character, Dennis Hope,
in "Almost Famous."
Yeah, that's me
right there, everybody.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Is Dennis Hope -- is my
character still in the play?
-I'm really glad
you bring this up,
because, Jimmy, we love
Dennis Hope of the movie,
and, as you know, we became kind
of a family making the film
because we were together
for a long time,
kind of going through
rock school
and teaching Billy Crudup how to
play guitar and everything.
You came in and rocked
your scene so well
as the manager of the future,
who kind of glimpses
all that's coming in terms of
rock getting bigger.
So of course it's in the play.
And my dream has
always been to have you
come and be the link between
the two casts,
the cast of the musical,
who also became
a really tight family,
and the movie.
So I would like you to come on
the Broadway stage
and play your part again
of Dennis Hope.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really?
-Yes.
-I am in!
I would be -- I would --
Absolutely, I am in.
Oh, my gosh!
♪♪
Who plays it now?
-We have a wonderful actor named
Jakeim Hart, a great musician.
-I'll talk to Jakeim.
We'll work it out.
-Jakeim will be around.
But the thing is, like,
knowing you might step in,
I rewrote the scene for,
you know,
kind of advanced Jimmy fever.
Like, I really wanted to get
a scene worthy of you, you know.
And the beard.
-Yeah.
-And so I wrote a new version
of the scene for you,
which turned out to be so great
that that's what's in the play,
and Jakeim does that version.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
So, it's got some new jokes
that I bring to you.
And it's fun.
But it's kind of like
a band, right?
It's like the cast
is a little bit like a band.
Come and jam with us.
-I want to jam.
-Yeah.
-I'm going to jam with the band.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also want to say,
in the playbill,
you dedicate the show
to your mom,
who, luckily, I got to meet.
And she would have been
so proud of this.
-Thanks, buddy.
-This is a giant deal, buddy.
I'm so happy for you.
It is so fun.
It is, again, musical.
It is funny.
It's got heart.
And it's written by
an Oscar-winning writer.
So what more do you want?
I love you, buddy.
-Love you, man.
-Cameron Crowe!
-Thank you.
-When we come back,
the cast of the Broadway show
"Almost Famous"
is performing "Tiny Dancer."
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back!